speaker is
julia panoff she's the associate
director at the tower bioinformatics
research center at haifa university in
israel
where
she is working on big data omics
analysis integration and modeling she is
involved in different projects including
analysis of whole genome sequencing
single cell sequencing proteomics and
phospho proteomics mass spec data as
well as others and she is now finishing
her phd studies at
dr kavsan's lab in neurobiology where
she has been studying molecular
mechanisms of neurodevelopmental
disorders using a variety of
bioinformatics tools and so julia will
speak to us today about analysis of
whole genome sequence data in cancer
studies as well as analysis of single
cell transcriptomic data and bulk rna
deconvolution approaches so
julia over to you
okay can you try now
yes thank you
um thank you very much for the
introduction
yep
thank you for the introduction and um
thank you everybody
uh so today i want to share with you a
little bit of the ongoing projects that
we are doing at the tower bioinformatics
research center
and that i have been involved in um and
which have become the basis of three
newly developed sections on the t
bioinfo platform
so first i want to introduce you a
little bit to the taobao bioinformatics
research center
um
so
talk about
maybe i can start sharing my screen
so talber bioinformatics
research center is a research center at
the university of fifa in israel
and we are a team of biologists
bioinformaticians and computer
scientists and our main goal
of the center is to make bioinformatics
tools accessible to a wide range of
researchers
so for this we
are developing and maintaining and
updating this uh t bio info platform
which you can see right now that have
a wide array of
areas omix areas that we
upgrade
and
update
the platform has a user friendly
interface for analysis of different
types of omix data
so of course having access to such a
platform might assist in analyses
however
many times researchers coming from
different areas of expertise don't know
where to start or how best to utilize
the tools available on the platform
even if the tools are quite easy for use
and don't need extensive knowledge of
algorithms that are behind the tools
so
we collaborate with pine biotech team
on development of tutorials and study
materials example projects
short courses and specializations
to enable research to quickly start
using the platform for their own
research
um
so today i will be sharing with you uh
two main projects that
our team tower team has been working on
for the past year or so
and based on which we have developed
three new uh
sections of the platform and at the
moment together with pine biotech team
we are working on writing up the
tutorials
and examples step-by-step
guides for running the pipelines that i
will be speaking about on the platform
and we hope that in a few months these
sections will be open for all the tbi
info platform users
so
the first project that i want to share
with you
will be a project dedicated to analysis
of whole genome sequencing data
that has been that we have been involved
but with and in collaboration with
professor
gutkoff from
roseville comprehensive cancer center
so this section was tailored actually
for tumor normal pairs of samples
from the same patient
however many of these tools can be
applied to a wide range of biological
questions
so
as you probably know
whole genome sequencing has become a
go-to technology for cancer research
it allows unprecedented understanding of
genome alteration at a single nucleotide
level
using bone genome sequencing technology
we can identify
genome duplications deletions
inversions
and insertions
as well as point mutations and changes
from
heterozygosity to homozygosity in cancer
cells
so this is the section that we have been
uh developing and working on and
and it includes pipelines that allow to
study uh all those chromosomal uh
alterations
point mutations driver genes
using control tumor pairs of samples
so in our project
for example we found great variability
in chromosomal instability what you see
here
on the left
right here is one of the
representative samples that we have been
working with
and we saw that some of the chromosomal
regions have up to 10 times
amplification of this region for example
in chromosome 12 of this genome
in another type of cancer another
representative
sample on the right
you can see that
much less events have happened and
the chromosomal instability is not as
as overwhelming as on the left however
still uh here we also see some uh
duplication events and some uh deletion
events as in chromosome 3 for example
if we look
more in details to these structural
variations and
types in different types of cancers
we found
that different cancers have of course
different structural variations
and
the pipelines allow us to look at
such variations as deletions
duplications
insertions inversions and translocations
of genomic
uh
loci
with
really
nucleotide uh
proficiency for example we can see exact
uh
exact uh
points where the
duplication has happened
the next uh
the next problem that a lot of cancer
researchers uh
are dealing with are
nucleotide uh alterations or mutations
and differences in mutation load in
normal and tumor samples
and there are basically two approaches
of looking at these
[Music]
point mutations we can either look at
cumulative distribution of
alterations
compared to the reference genome and
what you see on the left
is a graph is a comparison of a normal
tissue from the patient which is green
so
frequencies of mutations
in normal tissue
and by mutations here i mean alterations
from the reference genome and
alterations from their
reference genome in the tumor sample
which is represented by the red line
and we can see that there is faster
accumulation of low frequency mutations
in tumor and this
of course is in line with our
understanding of clonality of tumor
meaning that tumor cells do not have
similar mutations in all of the cells
and we can uh compare these
distributions of cumulative uh
mutations uh with uh
for example with uh kamagorov's narrow
statistic which will show us the
significance of difference between
these two distributions
on the right uh you can see a histogram
of the same actually distributions and
again we can see that
in while in
normal samples which are represented by
the blue lines
uh we see accumulation of differences
from the reference genome at about uh 50
so heterozygous
zygotic
[Music]
alternative alleles
in tumor samples we see this
accumulation at low
at
low frequency of mutations and also at
high frequency of mutations when uh when
heterozygous
alternative allows
are moved to
homozygous
a different approach is of course to
study somatic mutations in tumors
and
here the challenge is
uh in uh identifying a tumor purity and
of course
when we take
tumor samples they are not 100 pure uh
so that means that
a lot of uh reeds
from a tumor sample are actually coming
from
normal
cells
which
means that a lot of times it is hard to
identify
whether the particular
alteration is actual mutation
or it can be a mistake in sequencing or
mistake in alignment
so there are many
algorithms
that have been developed to finding
somatic mutations in tumor using a tumor
and normal pairs of samples taken from
the same
tissue from the same patient sorry
one of the gold standards is mutex ii
approach
algorithm which we also have
used for our study
and you can see that different cancers
have different
loads of somatic mutations
uh finally we can
also identify
driver mutations or driver genes
and
based on the
both on the genomic location of the
mutation
and the neighboring
sequences
next to the mutation
we can discriminate between
driver mutations mutations that drive
the evolution of the tumor and between
passenger mutations that appear in the
evolution of the tumor and again uh you
can see that we found some genes that
a putative driver
driver
genes of this particular cancer
and finally all of this
information a wide range of information
can be
put together in one graphical
representation that helps
put all the information together and if
we look at two uh cancers we see
that there is uh
there is a wide variety of
signals in two different cancers
so one particular
interest uh or
or recently it has been uh suggested as
uh one of the drivers of uh juno of
tumor evolution
uh is the somatic integrations of
repetitive elements in the genome into
the genome and as you might know
protein coding genes
are just a very small
portion of our genome of the human
genome and of all
mammalian genome and a big portion of
the genome is actually repetitive
elements that have not been studied
widely before but that have been
a focus over many studies recently
um
and
they
have a specific challenges computational
challenges because of their repetitive
uh
[Music]
sequence uh nature so these sequences
are actually very similar and they
appear
in many many places in the genome so a
standard approaches of aligning
reads onto those uh
until those regions fail
because all of the reeds
that actually come from different parts
of the genome align to
just several
parts of the genome and of course also
these regions are very hard to assemble
so many times
these
regions are
do not appear in reference
genome however
recently
it has been uh
one of the main
[Music]
repetitive element that has been proven
to be active and not only in tumor cells
but in other disorders as well is line
1. it is capable of
retrotransposition when it
when it is translated and can be
inserted into a different uh genomic
region and uh it has been shown that
usually those repetitive elements are
guarded against by
methylation
but in many disorders such as cancer
metabolic disorders neurological
disorders
and others there is hypomethylation of
the genome and these
and these
repetitive elements uh
are uh
do transpose and not only themselves but
also other repetitive elements and other
uh genomic elements so one of our
goals in this study was to study the
somatic
integration of these repetitive elements
into the tumor
in the genomes of tumor cells
and we have developed this uh
[Music]
pipelines that allow others also to
um study such somatic integrations of
repetitive elements
there have been
several other
algorithms developed recently that also
try to study these
um
these repetitive elements and their
integration into genome
and as i said earlier
it is
computationally it is challenging so we
cannot uh actually
uh we cannot uh use
uh standard uh tools that uh are used in
in uh for example uh regular genome
sequencing analyses so here for example
uh we have an approach where we use
split reads or we call them sometimes
hybrid reads when part of the read what
you see in black
is the sequencing pair and sequencing
read and we align the sequencing read to
the
repeat template
with part of the read hanging out and
then we uh
continue to
align the reeds to the reference genome
and by this way we can identify the
putative uh integration sites
either integration sites that are not
included in the reference genome
or integration sites that were already
in the reference genome so using this
approach
we found uh somatic sine integrations uh
in our two different types of cancer
and um
this is somatic integration
per cell
we also had matching rna sequencing uh
[Music]
data for the matching
[Music]
samples and so we compare to the
expression of the same sign
repetitive elements
with uh
the
with the somatic integration into the
genome and we found that uh the
expression of this
of these
signs
are mirrored in the somatic integrations
uh into the genome
uh
a different uh so this was our project
uh regarding the
whole genome
sequencing
and analysis of whole genome sequencing
data
next project that we uh
did in collaboration with uh
professor michelle levy from georgetown
university and his
lab
was
analysis of single nuclei rna-seq
data from
covered 19 patients
and we have developed
also we are developing
this
new
[Music]
tbilinfo
section that will
be
also available to all the
users
i hope soon uh so
uh as you probably know a single cell or
single nuclei rna-seq uh involves first
of all single cell suspension and then
uh single cell sequencing when cell
barcodes and
um barcodes which
barcode
actual mrna
molecules
are
connected to this
read and by
reading the cell barcodes and um
barcodes we can identify
which reads belong to which cells and
which molecules and by this way we can
get an expression matrix
or expression table
where we have
thousands of cells
from different patients for example
with of course
in
with expression of thousands of
genes
so uh we actually analyzed uh
recently um
a data set
from this uh publication from aviv
verges uh
team
from broad institute
they have uh
published uh
data from different organs of
sars
covet 19
patients
some and they also publish some
information about the patients
so we were interested in a kidney
organ and so we
analyzed the kidney data from these
patients
the first uh actually question that we
had and uh perhaps it is somehow related
to the talk that we heard from professor
andino
is whether uh covet 19 actually targets
uh kidney tissue
directly or whether what we see
of kidney
failure is not
because of the direct
[Music]
targeting uh by the
sars 2
[Music]
virus
so there is conflicting evidence
there are some reports that say that
coronavirus infection targets
directly the kidney
and others that
fail to replicate or that
do not find this to be true
we looked uh at our data actually
well not at our data but at the data
that we have been analyzing
and we also did not find any evidence of
uh reeds that came from sars cov2
genome
so uh
what we
studied is a host response
uh to the infection uh in covet 19
patients compared to controls
and what you see
here on the graph is a
after
batch corrections
and after normalization of the data
how
the different cells which are presented
as
points here
and
pink points
represent
cells coming from
19 patients and blue cells
blue points represent cells coming from
control
patients
and how
closely
they are
related and we can see that there is uh
some cells
that
appear to be different in covet 19
patients compared to control patients
uh now we were especially interested in
covert 19 patients that have
some
comorbidity
such as
obesity diabetes kidney disease
and so forth and covet 19 critical
patients that do not have these uh
comorbidities and of course we compared
them to the control patients and what
you see here is just the same uh actual
graph as you have seen before just
divided into those three types of
patients
and also
clustered so this clustering of cells
was done unsupervisedly
so that we actually cannot tell
at the moment which cells
belong
which cells we are looking at we just
know that uh cells
uh in cluster one for example uh
transcriptionally they are very similar
uh
to each other
and are probably very different from
another cluster such as cluster eight
so uh in this um
what right away i think uh is uh
evidence from this
visualization
is that
cells from cluster one
it seems like uh control patients almost
have no cells in this cluster one
and uh if to present a different uh
cluster for example in cluster zero
we see that most of the most
that actually uh covet 19 patients have
less
cells in cluster zero than the control
patients and it can be argued whether uh
covert 19 patients with
morbidity
have more cells or not
and we are working right now on
identifying whether this is true or not
however
this does not answer one of the most
important questions and that is
which cells exactly are we talking about
when we talk about this cluster one
so there are uh several approaches to uh
try to annotate
the
types of cells that we are looking at
and uh this is our
[Music]
attempt and i have to say that this
exercise did not go very well
and i will share with you uh in a minute
why
uh but uh
the
uh known uh marker genes that we have
used to identify
uh
the cell types for these clusters seem
to not work very well for example
some of the protocyte markers
one of the cell types in kidneys
are those three genes presented on the
left and you can see that here uh the
podocyte uh cluster
uh actually isn't
these gene these markers are expressed
in this uh part of the uh
of the graph
which is uh here so we can say that
actually podocytes
we were able to identify which cluster
belongs to the
podocytes uh and also with in the
celial cell markers we were quite
successful in identifying this cluster
as uh protocytes
however uh what we were really hoping to
see
is a cluster of
different clusters of different immune
cells that would point to
[Music]
to
immune infiltration
or infiltration of the immune cells into
the kidney however when we
looked at the
[Music]
at the
markers of immune cells for example
monocyte markers
we saw that there were almost uh no uh
cells
that expressed these markers and also b
cell markers we did not see any almost
no cells that expressed these markers
and um
these uh failings can be uh related to
the type of data that we are
investigating which is a single nuclei
data which has been shown in the past
to be biased against
catching
immune cells different types of immune
cells at least in kidney
tissue
so perhaps
sorry to interrupt we're a little bit
running behind on time
um so i wonder if we can wrap up in
another minute or less
yes i'm almost finished okay thank you
so of course for each uh
for each cluster whether it will be a
cell type or uh
or
just a cluster without a specific cell
type we can identify the uh molecular
pathways uh that are either activated or
suppressed in orbit 19 patients compared
to the controls
and also we can try to identify the
differences in the cell populations
between control and disease states which
we also try to do here
um so i want to uh finally thank uh
tauber bioinformatics team and our
collaborators at roosevelt park and at
georgetown university
and special thanks to professor tauber
for um
for his uh
support of our activities
and uh thank you for listening